Imagine an ecosystem made entirely of autonomous
machines. Where every ecological niche is filled
by an artificial organism. In the video game
‘Horizon: Zero Dawn,’ a global calamity has
led to a version of planet Earth inhabited
by animal-mimicking machines — from mighty
herbivores to deadly predators. While these
synthetic creatures might not be ‘biological,’
their fascinating interactions, unique behavioral
patterns, and hidden intricacies make them worthy
of study. The story takes place thousands
of years in the future, but a little thing
like the flow of time isn’t going to stop
this archivist from doing his fieldwork.
So, for this entry into the archive, I’ll lead
us on another documentary style expedition,
investigating the artificial ‘biology’ of
these intriguing machines and revealing what
animal roles they fill. We’ll need, though, to
stay alert—there are constant dangers in this
environment. Now, let’s leap forward in time,
and discover an ecosystem of metal and wire...
Beginning in the safety of a region known as the
Embrace, we find a picturesque landscape that
shows little signs of a planet-wide calamity.
Across much of the land, wounds of old have
long since healed — although this reborn Earth is
much changed from the peak of human civilization.
Small populations of human hunter-gatherers
still inhabit this land — although most live
within meager settlements, ever fearful of the
strange metal creatures that roam the woods,
whose function they have long forgotten.
Settling out into the wildness,
I find that some organic animal life does persist
in the shifting underbrush. But the roles they
fill are small and infrequent, for this is no
longer their world. Peering out from the grass,
I spot a being roughly the size of a horse. Our
first machine. This is a Strider — a basic type
of synthetic creature that fills the function of
an herbivore. Like organic herbivores, Striders
spend much of their time quietly grazing in small
herds, moving from one patch of grass to another.
Yet what use does a machine have for grass?
The answer lies in a small canister located
between the Strider’s haunches. This container
is filled with a green liquid called Blaze,
a type of biofuel synthesized from plants that
is foundational to the artificial ecosystem
of this world. The Striders are machines that
convert grass into fuel — much like how any
living herbivore essentially uses vegetation to
power their bodies. Striders also bring blaze back
to autonomous factories called Cauldrons, which
continue to repair and replace machines long after
being forgotten. Yet this energy source makes
Striders a target for human hunter-gatherers.
This means that — like most herbivores — a
Strider’s life is one of constant vigilance.
When threat looms, their optical sensors turn an
uneasy orange. Skittish by nature, the Strider’s
first instinct when human hunters are near is to
run. And like horses, when the herd takes off,
they can move with breathtaking speed. With
all four legs pumping, they can easily outrun
most dangers, only slowing when the coast is
clear. Not wanting to disturb these creatures,
I try to stay out of sight… …But that is easier
said than done. For guarding the outskirts of the
herd is a new type of machine. This is a Watcher,
and they make fieldwork a challenge. These small,
bipedal beings spend their existence tirelessly
patrolling the perimeter of the Strider herd. And
precious little slips past their optical sensors
unnoticed. Animals serving as lookouts isn’t
unheard of in nature, with the designated sentry
a key role in meerkat society, for example. But
this sort of coordination between two species
(so to speak), is something unique to machines.
By warning the Striders of imminent dangers,
Watchers are almost like living security cameras.
Well… living in a sense. And they also play
the role of bodyguard. With surprising speed,
Watchers can launch themselves into a flying
kick. It’s an impressive, if unwieldy strategy.
Yet Watchers will fight to the very end while
the Strider herd flees, and unfortunately,
one has spotted me. Launching into their signature
kick, a Watcher misses my head, and suffers a
pretty serious wipeout. Stumbling to their feet,
they seem rattled, but unharmed. Only their pride
is bruised. Not wanting to be insensitive,
I give my unsuccessful assailant the slip.
Going forwards, I’ll have to be more careful, as
there are far more dangerous things than Watchers
in this world of machines… To the north of the
Embrace, my path takes me to a region strewn with
the scars of civilization. The crumbling remnants
of buildings have been all but swallowed up by the
steady encroachment of nature. Yet even after a
thousand years, a quiet melancholy still clings to
this site. Yet there are machines in this broken,
unpredictable landscape. The deer-like Grazers
are adaptable enough to brave this region. Native
to the rolling fields beyond the ruin’s outskirts,
Grazers possess a pair of metallic
antler-like structures that serve
a curious function. On the ends of these
structures are a set of rotor blades,
which the Grazers use to shred grass and dirt
like sentient lawnmowers. With this unusual setup,
Grazers can consume plant matter faster than any
other machine. And like deer, where there is one
Grazer, there are invariably others. A herd of
grazers, all with their heads shoved in the dirt,
is an odd sight indeed. Yet Grazers don’t
have time to worry about their image,
as with four canisters of biofuel to fill,
they’re always on the move. But when a Grazer
feels threatened, their antlers have another
function. When I move too close to one Grazer,
the machine takes a fearsome swipe at me. A
narrow miss. As lithe herbivore-analogues,
Grazers aren’t built for combat, and so this
unit scampers away once I stand my ground…
Journeying deeper into the city ruins,
I find the feeling of desolation grows.
In this graveyard of humanity, I sense something
is lurking just out of sight. A terrifying machine
haunts this landscape. A Sawtooth. Rippling
with synthetic muscle, this cat-like hunter
is the equivalent of an apex predator in the
machine ecosystem. Their metal jaws come equipped
with a pair of curved, serrated spikes, which
resemble the formidable fangs of the largest
saber-toothed cats. There are rumors among the
local humans that the Cauldrons have been making
larger and more dangerous machines in recent years
— and looking at the Sawtooth, I don’t doubt it...
A machine this large might not seem capable of
great speed. Yet when a Sawtooth catches a target
in the open, they can move with incredible
agility. Aside from their fangs, Sawtooths also
possess claws powerful enough to shred through the
metal of these ruins. Trying to fight or run from
a Sawtooth is futile. The only way I’ll live to
archive another day, is if I avoid the Sawtooth
altogether. These ruins are their domain now, and
the time has come to make my exit. As the machines
continue to nurture the ecosystem, nature will
eventually reclaim this region entirely, leaving
behind no trace of the people who lived here. Even
monuments of metal and stone can’t last forever…
Venturing to the west, I find a vast scrubland,
baking in the sweltering rays of the rising sun.
Yet machines have conquered this
unforgiving environment as well,
with unique adaptations to brave the arid region.
These are Longlegs — machines with a tall,
bird-like appearance. Like the ostriches of today,
Longlegs are stuck on the ground, unable to take
flight. Yet through my observations, I’ve found
that Longlegs have a hidden ability. Mounted on
their chest are two bulbous sacs that resemble
external lungs. These artificial sacs are,
in fact, sonic amplifiers. When a Longleg feels
threatened, they can unleash a booming, concussive
soundwave so powerful it sends particulates
flying. For this reason, I’d recommend wearing
serious ear protection when observing Longlegs up
close. Aside from their soundwaves, Longlegs are
also capable of alarming bursts of speed. They’ll
even leap into astonishing flying kicks, which
look both beautiful… and frankly absurd. All in
all, these unusual machines are better left alone…
My intuition takes me northwards, where I
find a ruined landscape of twisted metal.
This rusted necropolis is a vast scrapyard –
the skeletal remnants of human civilization.
And a unique kind of machine has come to pick
these metal bones clean. Prowling in the shadows
of the junkyard are packs of Scrappers. Small but
deadly, Scrappers rule over this ruined kingdom.
With their humped posture and clawed feet,
Scrappers resemble the skulking forms of hyenas.
And like hyenas, Scrappers can be uncommonly
vicious. Yet there is another side to these
seemingly simple terrors. Scrapper jaws are
composed of four unique circular grinders.
But these jaws aren’t just for hunting. True to
their name, Scrappers use their curious mouths
to recycle metal resources. In grinding down
salvage piles and the bodies of inactive machines,
the Scrappers gather materials that can be used in
the construction of more synthetic life. And so,
these machines fill a role similar to
scavengers in this ecosystem of metal,
and improve the health of the environment. Yet
Scrappers aren’t purely altruistic. If were
to be spotted by one, they would waste no time
in trying to recycle me. For any non-machines,
this metal cemetery is a treacherous place...
Amid the dry badlands, the flow of rivers creates
isolated pockets of vegetation. And patrolling
rare wetlands are one-of-a-kind machines.
Shell-Walkers. These scuttling oddities move
on six stout legs, and can brave both wet
and dry terrain. And unlike all other types of
machines I’ve observed so far, Shell-Walkers
double as transport vehicles — a class dedicated
to ferrying materials back to Cauldrons. They
carry their quarry in hexagonal cargo containers
on their back, which they swap regularly. With
their ever-changing shells, a Shell-Walker’s
lifestyle mirrors that of a hermit crab.
If you ask me, a futuristic robot converging
on a crab makes complete sense, as crabs are
the pinnacle of evolution. And Shell-Walkers will
defend their cargo to the end. On their frontside,
Shell-Walkers possess two powerful arms — one
tipped with a formidable claw… and the other with
a mysterious, circular disc. Upon moving closer,
I discover this is some form of energy shield
generator — that the Shell-Walkers can deploy to
protect their left side while they attack with
their right. While energy shields are certainly
unique to machines, this sort of asymmetrical
defensive setup can also be found in the natural
world. Fiddler crabs are armed with one claw that
is significantly larger than the other, which they
use to fight over burrows. With their versatile,
crab-like body, Shell-Walkers are well
equipped to traverse this unpredictable world.
Speaking of which, as I venture into the
western wastes, the climate becomes even
harsher. Rusting under the afternoon sun
are the remains of a great satellite array.
Before the world fell to ruin, these
dishes might have been for communication,
hurtling signals out to the stars. Yet now, these
ruins send no messages save a silent reminder that
nothing lasts forever. And seemingly on cue,
circling overhead are what appears to be a
flock of vultures — a universal omen of grim
tidings. Yet like most creatures in this land,
these foragers are made of metal.
I’ve entered into the territory
of Glinthawks. These aerial machines keep a grim
vigil over this stretch of the badlands. Their
exceptionally keen eyesight means that little
slips through this region without their notice.
Yet despite their fearsome appearance, Glinthawks
play an important role in the machine biosphere.
Wherever the carcass of non-functional machines
can be found, a Glinthawk is sure to be nearby,
breaking down the metal for resources in a manner
similar to a Scrapper. Like modern vultures,
Glinthawks are obligate scavengers, breaking down
the parts others leave behind. It’s an unsettling
profession, but someone has to do it. As long as
the flock is distracted with their salvage duties,
I should be safe to pass through this area if
I do so cautiously. Yet one Glinthawk seems to
have grown wise to my presence. In a surprising
turn, the metal fiend sends volley after volley
of freezing liquid my way. This is actually the
Glinthawk’s coolant, which they can jettison from
their bodies as a kind of chemical defense.
Fleeing across the desert, I find that this
Glinthawk, thankfully, doesn’t seem interested
in an extended chase. Why bother with a moving
target, when there are so many stationary ones
strewn among the sands of this perilous expanse?
If I don’t wish to be claimed by this land myself,
I need to find a way to escape this heat. A cool
dip in the water seems promising… except this
river is occupied. Swimming just under the surface
is a huge Snapmaw. These imposing machines are
a force to be reckoned with both in the water
and on land. Everything from their gait, to their
anatomy, to their general behavior closely mirrors
that of crocodiles. Yet if the jaws of crocodiles
weren’t frightening enough, the lower mandible of
the Snapmaw is actually a chainsaw-like blade
with a system of small grinders at its base.
If one strays too close to the water’s edge, it’s
over in an instant. Keeping my distance from the
riverbank, however, I notice Snapmaws actually
spend most of their time basking in the sun’s
rays. Like many so-called ‘cold-blooded’ animals,
crocodiles sun themselves to increase their body
temperature. Yet what reason might a machine have
for regular sunbathing? The answer lies in the
rows of solar panels lining the Snapmaws back.
This clever energy-gathering array means that
even when a Snapmaw seems to be inactive, they
are actually gaining the power needed for their
daily movements. In this land, even a machine
as menacing as a Snapmaw has hidden intricacies…
With a swim seeming unwise, I escape the heat
with a change in elevation. Throughout the waste,
isolated plateaus rise so high
their peaks are crowned with snow.
In these frigid microclimates, the strange
landscapes are home to even stranger
machines. Trudging through the snow is a bizarre
procession of Freeze Bellowbacks. These hardy,
slow-moving machines are well acclimated to the
world of ice and snow. With their sloped posture,
Bellowbacks subtly echo the body plan
of therapod dinosaurs like Baryonyx.
As another type of transport machine, Freeze
Bellowbacks carry large reserves of coolant in
hefty cargo sacs on their back, and four smaller
sacs under their neck. When perturbed, Freeze
Bellowbacks will spray a high-pressure stream of
coolant from their nozzle. It’s a devastating and
effective defense mechanism, even if it looks…
a bit like sneezing. In these low temperatures,
a blast of coolant can be deadly. I think it’s
best to let the Bellowback procession pass on by…
Hiking down to the base of the snowy mesa, I
am drawn to the sound of thundering footsteps.
Creeping closer, I stumble into the midst
of a herd of giants. These are Behemoths,
beasts that look like they could carry the weight
of a mountain — or smash their way through one.
Like the largest rhinos or elephants, Behemoths
are the megafauna of the environment of machines.
The mightiest of the transport class, their
belly has a large space into which a circular
cargo container is locked in place by clamps.
And like all transport machines, Behemoths are
fiercely protective when it comes to their cargo.
In awe, I watch from a distance as a Behemoth
levitates a ring of boulders using anti-gravity
technology, then slams them down with a force so
great it shakes the valley. This mysterious power,
made possible through a forgotten technology,
makes the Behemoths an insurmountable force.
While they typically use this power to gather
minerals and other materials for transport,
if I’m spotted, these giants won’t hesitate to
unleash their crushing force to end my expedition
prematurely. Worrying as such an outcome might be,
I can’t help but stay transfixed
by the strength of these beings.
In time, however, the convoy lumbers on,
continuing their steady march across the valley…
Travelling as far west as I dare venture, I reach
a region where the greatest terror of the machine
world dwells. No amount of prior observation
prepares me for the sight that is the Thunderjaw.
Bristling with advanced weaponry, from tip to
tail, the Thunderjaw is a bringer of pure dread.
In terms of size and sheer might, they
represent a strength not seen in this region
since the Tyrannosaurus Rex some ninety-million
years ago. And unlike most machines, this metal
super-predator’s sole function is combat. From
their jaws, an array of cannons bring destruction
like the breath of a dragon. On their hips are a
pair of disk launchers, which rain down fire and
smoke from above. Even without their futuristic
weaponry, a Thunderjaw is still more than capable
of dispatching any threat, with their massive
tail perhaps their greatest weapon of all. The
further I stay from this machine, the better. Yet
in the glow of the setting sun, even a Thunderjaw
can look majestic. Without a visible target,
Thunderjaws behave like most any animal, plodding
about their environment at a leisurely pace. While
I watch the Thunderjaw pass on, I can’t help but
wonder what this land might be like if machines
and humans weren’t so diametrically opposed...
But my journey is not over yet.
At the edge of a shimmering lake,
footsteps echo over the water — so loud the entire
land seems to tremble in anticipation. Overhead,
the largest machine I’ve ever seen appears to
eclipse the very sun. This moving landmark is a
Tallneck. They can be found across many different
environments, although their numbers are scarce.
Unlike every other machine I’ve documented today,
these beings are in no way distrustful of humans.
With their silhouette and gait, Tallnecks
seem somewhere between a Giraffe and the
largest sauropod dinosaurs. The strange disk that
functions like the Tallneck’s head serves as a
communications array, sending information
to and from other machines. In this way,
the solitary Tallnecks act as the unofficial
hubs of the machine ecosystems. It’s a vital,
yet seemingly lonely purpose, as the Tallnecks
spend their existence walking in an eternal loop,
never thanked for their vital contribution to
the machine biosphere. Perhaps the Tallnecks are
oblivious to their surroundings, or perhaps they
get lonesome on their isolated march. Though I’m
well aware I’m likely projecting my own emotions
onto the Tallnecks, I decide to stay with the
beasts as long as I am able. After all, a path can
be a little less lonely when walked with a friend…
There’s much we’ve uncovered about this world of
machines, yet many key mysteries remain unsolved.
From the dense jungles of the south, to the frozen
wilds of the far north, there are a whole host of
machines I’ve yet to document, and secrets I’ve
yet to uncover. We’ll venture further across
the world of Horizon: Zero Dawn in Part Two,
exploring the more bizarre and more dangerous
machines in the lost reaches of the world. But
for now, our journey is at an end… As always,
thanks for watching. If you enjoyed this entry,
please lend your support and like, subscribe,
and hit the notification icon to stay up to date
on all things Curious. See you in the next video.